I
hey there goes one of those petticoats
soldiers now yeah my sister wants to
join the wax what are you thinking that
huh she's crazy what the devil's a woman
want to be a soldier for just a waste of
time this is a man's war what sort of
jobs can they do what sort of jobs can
we do take a look mr. x-ray technicians
inspectors of army meet teachers
schooling our soldiers wax our
classification experts assignment
interviewers so this is a man's war is
it wax are at work on every sort of army
vehicle doing every sort of Motor
Transport job testing walkie-talkies
testing radio choose those are just a
few of the jobs they do there are 239
more hey you two armchair generals on
the porch is something more for you to
think about listen General Eisenhower
said in many jobs wax do the work of two
men the army needs and can use all it
can get and listen to the women of the
United Nations late to have some ideas
on the subject the English were there
calm courage but stalwart women if
they're all aggression the Canadian and
Australian women the women of China with
their undying fortitude and tens of
thousands of American wax what are their
ideas on the subject listen
we shall give up the legends of our
fighting men
where did these thousands come from
where will the United States Army get
thousands more thousands to back up
manpower for battle abroad who are the
women who will help retain the needed
manpower for the production battle at
home who are the women who will help
fight our country's war Mary Jones Jane
Doe it's the idle housewife in the girl
next door oh yes it's your war two
missin Mrs America here at Fort
Oglethorpe in Georgia one of the most
beautiful army posts in the world we the
newly hatched blacks Gavin learned what
all the shootings about our kind of
shooting
the morning tonight we hustle through a
very novel interesting life not just
classes and drill and duty but all kinds
of women's sports and recreation we work
hard and play hard
we learn that the Army's privileges as
well as its hardships are ours we get /
low rates on trains special prices of
theatres special life insurance rates we
know that the rumors about the wax are
so much hot air so much that one out off
duty rayon or whatever you can get you
can't use make uh no room no let's turn
help our room don't lip stain own elbow
room no let's say no now toss that one
in the ashcan the same nonsense our hair
dress is up to us as long as it's neat
smart and off the color oh no fun all
work and no fun strictly access
propaganda from wack training centers at
Fort Oglethorpe and at Des Moines wax go
forth to army post cans specialist
schools Air Base to every part of the
United States Savannah st. Louis Newport
Baton Rouge Seattle Santa Barbara
to Washington our nation's capital come
hundreds of wax many to be stationed in
the famous Pentagon building and
attached to the combined Chiefs of Staff
wax are entrusted with tasks involving
the utmost secrecy here the important
work of decoding messages whose
information must be carefully guarded
and transcribed with perfect accuracy at
aberdeen proving grounds valuable men
have been released for combat duty by
wax inspecting mammoth tax computing
ordnance firing tables for the light
accurate american carbines the carbines
that have cancelled the effectiveness of
many and not see in many a jet here they
also check the efficiency of remote
control units and make secret ballistic
measurements these are just a few of the
important and interesting jobs done by
wax at air bases here and overseas women
soldiers perform over 25 technical jobs
war jobs now but civilian careers later
on we are in the machine shop in the
repair shop we rigged the parachute we
guide our flyers home altitude 5,000
feet 5000 request landing instructions
mitchel field tower to army 3131 circle
field twice at 3,000 feet on the end
will you I've got a heavy date tonight
hmm keep your chute on lieutenant heels
won't be clear for five minutes
potential American pilots are taught
blind flying by our wax they are taught
to handle night raids over Europe and
the black Pacific taught to navigate
safely through black space loaded with
hidden peril
thousands of wax volunteer for overseas
Duty eager to serve in the actual
theater of operations the goal toward
which they've worked and trained
wherever the American armies will go wax
may follow
women have proven that definite value in
England in North Africa in Algiers in
New Caledonian India and Egypt every
whack making the war shorter by a month
a week a day minute
yes wherever the American armies will go
wax may pollos to Berlin and Tokyo to
ladies and gentlemen general motion the
Women's Army Corps is an integral part
of the army of the United States and its
members who are soldiers in every sense
of the word the form of full military
part in this war there are hundreds of
important army jobs which women can
perform as effectively as men in fact we
find that they can do some of these jobs
much better than the man as more and
more American soldiers engage the enemy
in combat women must replace them at
overseas bases and at posts in this
country in view of the urgency of the
situation enlistment in the military
service should take precedence in my
opinion over any other responsibilities
except imperative family obligation
in 1918 we were on the sidelines
when the war has been one women in the
army will march shoulder to shoulder
with the man in the great victory
parades it will celebrate your turn of
peace to the world